Laurie Lachlan filing her first defense
move this asked her fuller house co-star
speaks out she pled not guilty Riesling
to those conspiracy charges
I think I'm under qualified and I've
also well we go by carrier pigeon Bob
Saget talking about his longtime co-star
this morning on today I will say that I
love her and I will say that no comment
and that's a it's a personal thing it's
a strange time and what do you say
Bob's comments come as Lachlan files a
motion with the court tried to push the
pause button on the case against her and
papers filed Monday along with fifteen
other defendants Laurie and her fashion
designer husband Massimo ask the court
to suspend all future actions by federal
prosecutors until they have an
opportunity to review the evidence
against them the request complains that
the defendants have not yet received any
discovery from the feds and they asked
for the opportunity to review the
evidence in a meaningful way if granted
the motion would be in effect until
their next hearing on June the third and
today prosecutors announced the USC
coach accused of helping Lockland
youngest daughter Olivia Jade get into
the school has agreed to plead guilty
and cooperate with authorities
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]